hi my name is Jonathan Jamie I'm a
professor of molecular biology at MIT I
kind of made my scientific living study
organisms little things cooking the
building blocks and machinery that all
living things depend on about the misted
nothing to do how it is good though our
seed becomes a plant how has becomes an
embryo in the 1970s most of the nation's
who were all trying to treaty the
biological weapons convention strongest
disarmament treaty human history it ban
the use of your weapons ban the
development and the stock piling up and
we really thought we had put a genie
back in the box but then in the early
1980s President Reagan revived climbing
the soviet union with needle empire and
you would by sending my tax dollars on
biological weapons he called my life in
the pension program hopefully go old
laboratories and that together with a
few colleagues we organized the national
campaign as you campaign of biological
scientists who play that they would not
use this killer talents to work on
military issues of my logic analogy and
we were able to get enough publicity to
pressure the key Committee of the Senate
John Glenn the astronaut is done the
chair of it forget them click the key
steps will be ratifying the biological
weapons convention definitely a step
forward so we know these things can
happen nuclear weapons for anybody with
any concern for for living things
nuclear weapons which are clear rate
incinerated every living thing plants
animals in say Michael organisms worms
Eagles in the blast zone in a way that
they only cover problems without the
years this is have no place in human
society at all many many times and so
you know I'm here the united nations
would
many many other scientists hoping that
the United Nations will be free Crutcher
the man to get rid of these nuclear
weapons forever and rid the earth of the
scourge of this insane weapons
you